Dear friends,
you may know the list of sponsors
for the green
bundestelliertenkonferenz,
which took place recently.
There is a list
and there are just
many companies in the economy on it.
And dear friends,
that makes me wonder how can that be?
Degree the German economy,
just the companies in the country with us
become massively driven by left-wing green politics
also damaged the green one.
We are experiencing a build-up of,
we experience
a creeping and on speeding
D Industrialization
due to the so-called energy turnaround,
of the high energy prices,
which will also soon no longer be
uh will sink.
And we experience overall
awirtschaftsfeindlichkeit
with this federal government.
And that's when I ask myself,
so how can
the victims of this policy
even pay their worse?
And uh,
if you look at the list,
then there is also 1 company,
the state is the,
because the state hand is Deutsche Bahn.
And that's when I'm already wondering,
how can it be
are taxpayer money also wasted here?
So we have this open letter
also sent to the companies
and were there in response.
I already have an answer
and there it was then pointed out,
that this is a co-payment for a booth.
At least an answer
and at least one wonders there probably then nevertheless
behind closed doors,
which is what this is supposed to be.
The left-wing policy
may not be supported further.
We want our prosperity again
here in Germany.
You just can't do that with left green,
that only works with the AfD love!
Friends,
in this respect stay tuned
and I will soon also be here
report at this point,
as has progressed with this topic.